michael murphy is probably best known
for playing the mayor in batman returns
but that's not the only time he played
an authority figure in a superhero movie
nor is it the only time that paul rubens
has played the father of a certain
villain
would be willing to wager most folks
already know what michael keaton looks
like today as he still appears in movies
and tv shows on a regular basis even
though he turned 70 in 2021 he had lead
roles in back-to-back best picture oscar
winners 2014's birdman and 2015's
spotlight a few years later he then had
a small pivotal part and the aaron
sorkin directed the trial of the chicago
seven he then showed up on the hulu
miniseries dopestick for which he won a
screen actors guild award for
outstanding male actor in a tv movie or
mini series keaton focuses a tad more on
dramatic roles these days but if you
thought he was done with superheroes
after he passed on 1995's batman forever
it'd be highly mistaken in an ironic nod
to his time as the dark knight he played
the vulture another winged comic book
icon in 2017's spider-man homecoming and
he's even reportedly slated to reclaim
the cape and cowl and become batman once
again in 2022's the flash and hbo max's
batgirl
michelle pfeiffer's a-lister status has
hardly diminished since the early 90s
her notable recent projects include the
2017 horror parable mother as well as
the ensemble crime caper murdered on the
orient express also released in 2017 and
then her performance in 2020's french
exit garnered her a golden globe
nomination and as a case with michael
keaton as well as so many other actors
working today pfeiffer is no stranger to
the marvel cinematic universe she made
her first appearance as janet van dyne
the original wasp in 2019's ant-man and
the wasp and she's been confirmed to
reprise her role in 2023's ant-man and
the wasp quantomania and while several
other actors have played selena kyle in
various projects over the years none
have managed to convey anything like the
righteous mania of pfeiffer's version
three lives down you got enough in there
to finish me off
these days danny devito is most widely
recognized for playing a nihilistic
crime lord with megalomaniacal ambitions
we're speaking of course about disgraced
businessman frank reynolds on the
long-running sitcom it's always sunny in
philadelphia like the version of the
penguin that devito played in batman
returns frank has virtually zero
capacity for ethics and morals he's a
pathological liar a lech a manipulator
an embezzler and an irresponsible gun
owner however frank also has something
resembling a heart that occasionally
guides him towards altruism nothing we
see in batman returns however leads us
to believe that oswald cobblepot is
capable of any empathy at all then again
devito's penguin never gets to run a bar
with his lovable slimeball buddies if
oswald had the same second chance that
frank has enjoyed it'd probably still be
evil but somewhat less evil devito's
career includes plenty of other
highlights in addition to those iconic
characters he was a regular on the 70s
sitcom taxi and he starred in such
varied movies as the joel of the nile la
confidential and jumanji the next level
he's also an accomplished behind the
scenes operator having directed 1992's
hoffa in 2002's criminally underrated
death to smoochie
following his performance as diabolical
capitalist max shrek in batman returns
christopher walken contributed his
acting prowess to 1993's true romance
and 1994's pulp fiction he'll turn 80 in
2023 so it's perhaps unrealistic to
expect him to continue to crank out
classics at the same clip that he used
to regardless his schedule doesn't seem
to have slowed down all that much in
2022 alone he co-stars in the bbc one
series the outlaws as well as the apple
tv plus thriller severance walken has
also shown up in a few clunkers that
predated this recent shift to tv
including the 2020 family comedy the war
with grandpa as well as 2019's the jesus
roles which featured john totoro's
return to his minor character from the
big lebowski on the positive side
walking received considerable praise for
his performance as a humble farmer in
2022's percy vs goliath a considerable
turn against type considering how
closely he's been associated with
villainous roles throughout his career
and bruce wayne
why are you dressed up like batman
thanks to peewee's big adventure in 1985
and owning saturday morning kids tv from
1986 to 1990 with peewee's playhouse
paul rubins was already a certified
household name by the time of batman
returns release in 1992 decades later he
brought his alter ego back for one more
go round in 2016's peewee's big holiday
but beside that this comedy legend has
revisited his signature character
relatively infrequently since the 80s
pee-wee that's my name don't wear it out
nowadays rubens tends to show up here
and they're in various films and tv
shows having lately contributed cameos
to the abc game show to tell the truth
and the effects vampire mockumentary
what we do in the shadows astoundingly
enough for rubin's performance as the
penguins criminally negligent father in
batman returns is much smaller than his
other batman related roles at least in
terms of minutes on screen he provided
the voice of batmite in multiple
episodes of the 2009 animated series
batman the brave and the bold and he
played a much more sympathetic version
of the penguin's dad for an arc on fox's
batman prequel series gotham
casting diane salinger and paul rubins
as a penguin's parents was a clear
tribute to tim burton's directorial
debut peewee's big adventure in that
earlier feature salinger played simone
an adventurous woman who's trapped in a
loveless marriage and a dead end
waitressing job while salinger's hardly
the biggest name from batman returns she
has enjoyed a consistent and interesting
presence in film and tv since the mid
80s this has included stints on hbo's
mid-2000s dust bowl apocalypse drama
carnival and 2000's power rangers light
speed rescue for which she provided the
voice of queen bansheera salinger also
played a therapist in the 2001 cult
comedy ghost world which means that even
if she never gets her own marvel
franchise she's still the only actor on
this list who had a scene with steve
buscemi in thora burch's best movie
arguably underutilized in batman returns
michael murphy's character doesn't even
have an actual name listed on the film's
imdb page instead he's simply known as
meyer although he can at least rest
assured that the novelization of the
film reportedly does name this character
as roscoe jenkins as for murphy himself
he hasn't slowed down as much as you
might expect for someone in his 80s he
appears in netflix's 2019 bob dylan
documentary rolling thunder review and
he's provided voice overs for episodes
of pbs's american experience as recently
as 2020
having started his film and tv career in
the early 60s there's a lot more to
murphy than a medium-sized part in a
caped crusader flick he's known for his
several collaborations with director
robert altman and batman returns isn't
even his only significant superhero
movie as he played warren worthington
the third's dad in 2006's x-men the last
stand
former saturday night live staple jan
hux briefly pops up in batman returns as
jen one of mack shrek's personal image
consultants in addition to her snl
tenure from 1986 to 1991 her tv credits
include the likes of designing women
third rock from the sun and primetime
glick she passed away in 2014 at the age
of 57 and some present-day showbiz
movers and shakers think she was owed a
little more applause during her time on
earth during elle's women in hollywood
awards in 2014 tina fey profanely
declared jan should have had a bigger
career jan deserved a big movie career
certainly as big as rob schneider's
career she was a bigger star on snl
we're not saying tina fey is right all
the time even though she's plenty smart
and funny nobody is right 100 of the
time but we can say objectively and
definitively that when it comes to jan
hooks tina fey is unequivocally correct
if you ask us having his nose nearly
bitten off by the penguin during an
ill-advised image consultation session
is the zenith of steve whitting's career
but it's hardly his only on-screen
highlight as he's been a regular player
in the background of major film and tv
endeavors since the mid-80s he's
certainly been doing pretty okay in the
last decade or so especially when it
comes to movies directed by martin
scorsese as he showed up in 2010's
shutter island 2013's a wolf of wall
street and 2019's the irishman and he's
booked a role in scorsese's upcoming
western killers of the flower moon
whitting has additionally appeared in a
handful of the series most significant
tv shows including it's always sunny in
philadelphia and arrested development
and he also showed up in the 2020 hbo
miniseries the outsider and batman
returns wasn't his only collaboration in
1992 with danny devito as he showed up
in the devito helmed hoffa in which jack
nicholson plays the infamous labour
organizer who gave the film its name
most of the actors on this list don't
appear in all four entries of the series
that begins with 1989's batman and ends
with 1997's batman and robin but
tenacious michael goff is bruce wayne's
loyal butler alfred pennyworth
throughout the saga the latter two films
batman and robin and 1995's batman
forever aren't exactly the most
acclaimed entries in the cave's
crusaders on screen saga but even if
some of the movies that feature goth
aren't that good we doubt that
christopher nolan would have made sure
to hire someone on the level of michael
kane to play a new alfred in 2005's
batman begins if goff's portrayal
weren't a very tough act to follow goff
passed away in 2011 at the age of 94.
his on-screen career began in the 1940s
and he kept acting regularly throughout
the 90s with a handful of parts after
the year 2000 despite his appearances in
high-profile films like out of africa
and the boys from brazil his obituaries
understandably tended to focus on his
run as alfred
i think i'll take the stairs
commissioner james gordon didn't have a
ton to do during this particular era of
batman movies this version of gordon
played by veteran character actor pat
hingle has much more in common with the
noble bumbler portrayed by neil hamilton
in the campy 60s batman tv show than
with the determined every man channeled
by gary oldman in christopher nolan's
batman trilogy oddly enough the timing
of hingle's life and career make us
wonder why he wasn't cast in the 60s
batman during that era he routinely made
guest appearances on such iconic series
as mission impossible and the andy
griffith show imdb lists ridiculously
prolific hingle's first credits as a
1951 episode of suspense and his final
credit of the 2008 film called undoing
time with very little down time in
between he died in 2009 at the age of
84. despite having played literally
dozens of other parts the headlines of
hingo's obituaries largely emphasized
his batman related work
ironically the nameless organ grinder in
batman returns is played by one of the
most recognizable actors in the film
noted for his unusual facial features
vincent chiavelli arrived on plenty of
people's radar with his performance as a
mental institution patient in the 1975
classic one flew over the cuckoo's nest
as fate would have it cuckoo's nest also
marked a career milestone for fellow
future batman villains jack nicholson
and danny devito after cuckoo's nest
hollywood tap shively pretty much
whenever a distinctively odd but
non-threatening presence was required
this included parts in the likes of
1982's fast times at richmond high
1990's ghost and 1997's tomorrow never
dies additionally shia valley made guest
appearances on so many significant tv
series that we don't even know how to
start listing them but if we had to pick
one let's go with lanny the conjoined
twin from the 1995 x-files episode
humbug chiavelli passed away in 2005 at
the age of
57. my train
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]